pour sûr ce jeune homme a mangé beaucoup
de sauts de mettre 8 pour s'accrocher
salle fait 92 kg il n'en a pas l'air est
question pointures il est plutôt bien
dans ses baskets maxime karen 17 ans
vice champion du monde et champion
d'europe il a fait ses débuts avec
jérémy d'ici au sporting club du
lamentin il a été un peu réticent bon
communauté gonds tout est plus grand
avec les autres teams jouer et ça n'a
pas été facile
après la vue militaire qu'il avait sa
place à qu'il était important pour le
beau parent il a accepté de continuer le
basket il est donc très vite repéré un
temps dans les bras du pôle espoir
martinique puis c'est l'insep qui
l'accueille l'institut national du sport
de l'expertisé et de la performance
le haut niveau est synonyme de
persévérance de sacrifices je faisais
partie de la zone du magois c'est une
sélection guyane martinique guadeloupe à
l'issue de ce tournoi j'étais
sélectionnée pour le camp national
[Musique]
avec 60 joueurs et je suis parti au camp
national et après le conte nationale
j'ai été avec 30 he 30 joueurs j'ai été
sélectionné pour les testings siècle où
je suis pas inquiet à vincennes pendant
une semaine faire des tests et alice in
était-ce bien on m'a gardé
c'est beaucoup de sacrifices mais moi je
ne vois pas comme un sacrifice à partir
du moment où c'est ce que je vais faire
c'est une étape ou par laquelle je dois
passer pour y arriver et forcément c'est
difficile parce que c'est une autre
intensité qu'est ce qu'on peut connaître
ici en martinique
mais au bout de quelques mois on
s'habitue et sa douce est bien facile
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya quelquefois il
ya des moments de moins bien
et pendant ces moments là je peux
compter sur mes parents qui sont
toujours là avec moi fils unique ses
parents l'ont suivi en région parisienne
pour l'encourager d'ici la fin de
l'année scolaire
maxime sera sur le marché des
professionnels d'une basket convoité il
devra faire le bon choix